[Music]
Stephen you're gonna love this one
okay Tiffany let's see so there's a
nutrition coach who claims she has not
drink a single drop of water in the last
year's eve all of this who is she
she probably eats a lot of celery
married sheet mass [ __ ]
celery okay so her name is Sophie she
lives in Bali your favorite place in the
world that's not bad love Bali it's too
hot but quiet
sure so she claims that she has been dry
fasting for a year what does that mean
is she a prude what the [ __ ]
so she says that she drive fast every
day for 13 to 14 hours and then when she
does consume liquids she only drinks
living water which is juice from fruit
or just fruits in general so she tries
to she tries to get her nutrition is
dull considered living water pineapples
like the juice company well if it's
directly from a pineapple that's living
water according so directly from the
fruit she's still getting water content
from plants waiting how is it possible
cuz I thought your body doesn't absorb
water from [ __ ] drinks that that
aren't water [ __ ] well these are
natural fruits it doesn't [ __ ] matter
you ask if it's even even this right
it's this is called brew coffee thereby
merrily water primarily right there are
are there's water or there's why how
much water though it doesn't it's about
don't tell us it's mostly water that's
the whole point
but copies also a diuretic that's how
your systems paint that's why it makes
you flush obviously water right and then
all this [ __ ] where it's like okay
whatever the [ __ ] 160 milligrams of
caffeine per can like my body can barely
even absorb all that in one moment you
know the first one the first sign the
first sign of addict is denial
yes it is because Stevens usually benign
justifying not drinking water just do
I'm actually fine with water I drink
water now but I'm talking about where's
your water there is no life not more
tennis balls of water part I drink I
drink your propeller skate ok that meant
something to me I know I bought for you
I have the same argument though no no
point the but the point is that all the
Astra the aspartame study to everyone
always sites in saying like diets so
does a bad feeling [ __ ] was [ __ ] it
actually got debunked years later but
people don't member that they just
remember the bad guy read that news
right so that's what I'm saying is most
people cite garbage debunked science
when they talk about diet diet soda and
diet energy drinks in truth well she's
not talking about diet anything she's
talking about living water but her [ __ ]
also smells problem oh god I got no
alkaline I don't know man they might not
smell like nothing cuz it's dry she
actually is cleaning so she has like
this whole long has videos like Sabrina
smell her [ __ ] to see if it smells bad
no you're not just relating with zooming
salt and by consuming dead water which
is this kind of water she claims that's
good this is dead wash Kirkland's so she
says that bottled water only has
microplastics in it and then it doesn't
have it's only h2o but your body and
like on a cellular level it needs h3o or
something like that
oh hey Thank You h3o - and so that's
what your cells actually need and she's
saying that ever since she stopped
consuming dead water that now like she
has reduced a lot of puffiness and she's
a little she feels a lot healthier and
like her cells are better her skin has
improved so this is what she looks like
now oh [ __ ] how old is she 19 like 30
something like 30 so she looks there
she's 30 Sunday's 30
it's just bad lighting imma say it's bad
lighting oh that's not bad lighting
looks good she's 35 no what she would
look like before with water when she
would drink a lot of water cuz she said
that she was water allergy that happens
she got stung by a bee or something yeah
so she said that she retained a lot of
water and she was constantly swollen and
she was forever thirsty and like she
would drink like four liters of a day
she consuming a lot of [ __ ] sodium
and forgetting
take a water piece that's the same no
yeah this is no this is to show her skin
condition so she ate salty things well
so she also she also cut out sodium
completely from her diet so it's cutting
out dead water and sodium but allow me
with the next picture yes she does look
healthier better she does not look 3500
cheeks liquids she's drinking coconut
water it contains H ourselves the cells
need something more specific to be
utilized as water like monster 208 302
it's a substance which is also found in
fruits and vegetables besides that it's
German or something H 302 is what we
need and one for our body it is the
hydration onset alone level she's making
you thirsty
how much the problem with this is what
can she do if Michael Jordan can dunk
and eat drinks Gatorade imma drink
Gatorade what can she do cuz I don't see
her doing [ __ ] I doesn't make me want to
do what she's told me she could do
telekinesis I would say alright I'll try
yeah can she [ __ ] serve a 90 90 mile
per hour fastball in tennis court well
what she did she looks at lettuce is
amiss in her goal whoa what the hell is
our goal then in the Middle Ages in
Europe people consume or alcoholic
products than they did water because the
water supply wasn't very healthy and
then the fermentation made it yeah but
the alcohol content was so [ __ ] low
though it's not like the same beers that
we drink today not at all yep a part I
don't know any fitness questions
questions oh why doesn't a bodybuilder
just eat their day's worth of protein in
one meal how come they usually stage it
out because it's wave
more fun to spread around yeah cuz I
have a feeling that it's about how your
body can't absorb that much at one time
which is exactly what I didn't [ __ ]
talk about what I heard from all those
guys is you're both your body can
metabolize 40 grams of protein in a
sitting Thank You Bart and that's all
I've been saying I can't I can't
metabolize all this [ __ ] in one sitting
it's mostly just [ __ ] water that gets
pushed out of my [ __ ] body
he's not even a fitness guy true I just
like spreading the food around look I
get all my advice from a clown trust me
yeah I mean that's the reason why you
still drink anything so what point are
you trying to make cuz we're talking
about this [ __ ] but you're making it
about yourself if you were if you were
if you listen to what he says so let's
go in the water right it's not
surprising that fruits and vegetables
that are mostly comprised of water can
also give you that [ __ ] property
great body it's not surprising so but
but for a lot of people out there who
think like I have to drink certain um
one out of water a days this many ounces
they look at this and go that seems like
it's insane and so this gets [ __ ]
times or clicks even though it's pretty
much common no the part that water blows
my mind is too dry fasting does that
mean she's just being dehydrated yeah
for thirteen hours she said because dry
fasting what is that like did they talk
about how you do dry fasting so there's
okay so it says here dry fasting or
absolute fasting restricts both food and
liquid it doesn't allow any any fluids
including water broth and tea this is
different for most fast which incur or
encourage water intake so then they're
saying that the benefits people who have
done this they say that they have
experienced weight loss improved immune
function cell regeneration reduced
inflammation skin benefits spiritual
benefits but it's closer to God she says
scale we're Jennifer get me know cell
regeneration so so wet know like what's
sale like what
because there's a Institute in Russia
that uses fasting as a way to curing
mental illness and health related
problems
yeah and then also you know during
Ramadan they do fasting as well but
that's only for one month so there's
that why Muslims got really good skin
they do a lot of people were commenting
in her in her video like this is
extremely dangerous you're giving very
dangerous advice and she doesn't look
like she got stung by bees anymore no
she looks good face was so puffy before
I was word she said that she has cured
her aching joints her puffy eyes her
food allergies bad skin and digestive
issue that's hard to say because we
haven't isolated what she's allergic to
or whatever she might have a gluten
laughing or we don't know it people that
so this is the thing when people
drastically change things they always go
oh it's just one thing but I can totally
relate it to anything else cuz like like
for example in Fitness this happens all
the time when they change their diet and
they work out there's like it's like a
whole holistic change right and then
they go go on to the gym help me out
right but in reality it's like your
whole lifestyle change or even just like
somebody has an autoimmune disorder and
they go carnivore diet and that means
everyone should do carnivore diet no
it's it's specific to that person's
biology so like burner off her whole
picture she could have kicked her coke
cat habit she's smoking cigarettes like
12 cigarettes a day he should stop doing
that and in that but those are the
things that aren't in the picture that's
bull she could have like milk allergy
she quit like cheese but then she says
I'm a quit salt so cheese has salt or
whatever she says he cut off the people
might not know that it was actually the
cheese that was [ __ ] them all but
then when they when they made a journey
to quit all salt they actually took out
the cheese and all that yeah yeah so
yeah I mean that it's an entire
lifestyle change
I choose nothing it's just that one I do
want to experiment right on like going
super like primitive style where it's no
salt no sugar no processed it's fresh
food that is like caught in the jungle I
want to try that out sleep like regular
human hours right like no normal in the
I want to try this [ __ ] out I want to
try the [ __ ] out for a whole [ __ ]
year and see if it does anything to my
body and my mind of course it is how
different well I feel how different all
depends on what you're doing right if
Bart was running 20 miles tomorrow and
he's like I'm not drinking water I'm
gonna get all my [ __ ] out of fruits and
veggies he's [ __ ] right yes it all
depends on what you do that's the whole
picture I mentioned too late if anyone
is considering dry fasting or whatever
it is like only getting the nutrients
from fruits vegetables juices and
coconut water then you have to prepare
your body before you jump in the deep
end which is like drink more juices
there chill man more more fruits or
whatever before you end up doing this
crazy thing
get your [ __ ] Netflix cue figured out
get ready to binge to shake like I just
rather go on like [ __ ] and afraid and
try it for like 27 days why would you
take anything I'll do it I always wanted
to do negative frame but I'm just like
bro like I could handle like not eating
I can handle probably the weather and
being cold bugs
yes bugs this mission is sleepy survivor
dude let's do survivor you and me okay
and we'll have an alliance going in okay
okay what oh and they want again they
won't expect us and then they won't
suspect a big conflict and you guys had
to join yes
[Music]
you
you